laura good morning good morning how are
we doing
good morning john thanks for taking my
call thank you for calling in how can i
help
yeah i'm hoping to just gain some
insight and possible direction on how to
um navigate a
marriage relationship with a person who
has adhd
oh i feel like you're um typecasting me
here that i may or may not have that
myself
yeah i mean it's all of it it's tricky
because it's all the adhd things that i
love most about him and that's why we
fell in love he
just has so much enthusiasm and such a
big heart and he's so much fun
um i i got divorced um from a previous
marriage and have two kids that i have
primary custody of
and he just jumped right in and no
hesitation just wrapped his arms right
around them and it's just been such a
good fun dab for them
um there's just so many things about the
adhd and just who he is as a person that
i love
but now as time has gone on over this
relationship
i didn't really understand adhd and its
full effect on adults
and relationships and we've kind of just
been unknowingly playing into
what i'm learning now as a pretty
classic toxic relationship dance between
a non-adhd and an untreated adhd partner
excellent so so explain some of the
things you are learning
they're probably going to sound a lot
like my home go ahead
yeah well there's there's a lot of that
parent child dynamic where i kind of
just take on
the majority of the load for our family
being the responsible one and the person
that follows through and has that
executive functioning
and um i have been diagnosed with
complex ptsd which makes
which lends me towards being the more
over functioning kind of controlling
partner
okay and so it's been easy for us to
kind of just get stuck in that dance
where i'm trying
to where i'm trying to boss them around
and remind them to do all of these kind
of just basic adult things
right does this play a pretty a pretty
significant
put a pretty significant strain on your
intimate life
yes yes a huge a huge strain on that for
sure it makes it really hard for me to
feel like i'm in a partnership with him
or that i'm like romantically
attracted to him when i feel like he's
just my third kid yeah i was going to
say
one of the the challenges that folks in
this type of
relationship struggle with is to just
put it out there
nobody wants to be intimate with her mom
and nobody wants to be intimate with
their kid
and the longer this goes the more that
golf those relationships get redefined
and
yeah did you struggle with this in your
previous marriage
no my previous marriage was just um and
it was an abusive situation i had to
just get out to protect myself and my
kids
so it was definitely different so you
you ran
um and i don't mean that negatively but
you ran into the arms
of someone who was the exact opposite
who is
almost has no filter on the relational
engagement part of his brain
who is all in all the time and more
importantly who let
you have the driver's seat in this time
right in this relationship you got to
drive you get to be the boss you get to
be mom
and that sounds so fun for the
screaming fearful part of your
relational brain that was in an abusive
relationship
and now it's way too much right
no fun yeah exactly and i was just that
single mom that was
juggling all the plates by myself and
was used to doing everything and he just
kind of slid in and was like sweet this
is great and comfy and
thanks so much i'm realizing wait
i'm doing everything and there's a
perfectly capable adult right here who's
not
yeah yes okay so how can i help
specifically in your situation
yeah i'm just hoping to get some tips
and guidance on how we can best navigate
it moving forward so we don't just get
stuck in a toxic spiral where we're um
just struggling to get along with each
other and struggling to remain attracted
to each other and those kinds of things
what are
what are some tips as far as that goes i
love it okay so the first thing i want
you to do is this
and i've mentioned his book several
times before
um i've got it here i'm going to hold it
up
man i brought this today this is just
couldn't be more extraordinary timing
here this is a book called scattered by
gabor mate
last name m-a-t-e and it's a
first-person narrative a science book
it's the best book on
adhd relationships and being in a
relationship with someone with adhd
i've ever come across in my life it is a
hard read and i mean hard not difficult
but hard emotionally it's been hard for
my wife to read it was hard for me going
through it one day when my kids read it
they're gonna have a hard time with it
and when i recommend it to people it's
hard here's why
add is not an illness in the medical
sense
right it is it drives me crazy when it
turns into a medical issue and because
we've
developed some medication that that
helps it a little bit
um we think it's it's a disease we think
it's a
medical dysfunction and it's not adhd
mate says it is a it's not a fixed
inherited brain disorder it's a
set of physiological biological
consequences
of an environment of behavior that's
allowed
and chaos right and so here's the thing
is your husband on medication of any
kind no he's not doing anything to treat
it right now
okay that's fine and i usually recommend
medication as
a second or third or fourth option
i don't mean to be graphic here but
medicine for adhd is a stop gap it can
be like
diarrhea medication can stop the
explosions right
it's not going to fix your core stomach
issues
what medication can do is help somebody
focus but that focus is only good
if they are using it to develop new
relational skills and really at the end
of the day
a person with adhd struggles with this
idea of
impulse control it's grown people acting
like children because they never
developed it's a developmental disorder
right
it's literally disordered thoughts for
folks who are listening to this
think of it this way dr mate gives this
great example
all the thoughts are traveling down a
highway and
there's a police officer there who is
stopping traffic coming this way and
he's waving it on just like a traffic
stop
for somebody with an adhd mind it's not
that their thoughts are out of control
it's just that the policeman is just
sitting down letting traffic go so they
all get in the same place at the same
time which
you know adhd medication is really a
stimulant
they fire your brain up and it helps
reorder some things and it doesn't sound
like somebody with adhd would need a
stimulant but it helps reorder helps get
that policeman back where they need to
be and they are directing traffic in the
right way
and so as we talked about man no mom
wants to hook up with their son no son
wants to hook up with their mom
right this change does not start well
it starts with you some but this change
really starts with your husband
your husband has to get exhausted with
being exhausted
now this is me this is the pot talking
to the kettle on this one okay
there had to be um a time in my life
when i just had to say enough is enough
is enough
adhd is a context
not an excuse what does that mean
that means that people with adhd often
struggle with magical time
time doesn't exist or i have to be at
work at 10 minutes it's a 30 minute
drive and i'm hopping into the shower at
9 55.
the fact that it's not 10 yet i got
plenty of time the people who work with
me here on this show they'll know
is that sound like something at your
house oh yeah
so hey you know what it's fine if the
kids just stay up till midnight tonight
to watch this movie
and twinkies have some nutritional value
we're gonna be fine mom we're gonna be
fine
and it will all work out tomorrow and
there is this magical
consequence-free environment that folks
live in here's the deal that's not
reality and that's not
true and a person with adhd has the
ability to know that that's not true
what they have to do is create go as far
as they can upstream and create systems
and context and behavior change in
themselves
that starts with this idea that he is
worth being loved
most people with adhd come from places
of either chaotic environments
or they come from environments where
people withheld there was neglect there
were people that
that didn't teach them ways to live and
love sometimes it's when people take
care of when parents take care of
all of their stuff for their kids
sometimes it's when parents
take care of none of their stuff for
their kids and kids are constantly
constantly constantly living in chaotic
environments
but he's got to learn to love himself
and when he learns to love himself then
he learns that he is worth
parenting himself and that begins with
cleaning up external chaos
you know cleaning environments being on
time um you know
getting sleep good nutrition but all
that stuff
you don't eat right if you don't think
you're worth it you don't sleep right
if i'm just another guy right
and that's when you come in
it starts with you sitting down or your
your part of this starts with you
sitting down with him and saying
i'm done being your mom i'm your wife
i'm in love with you
romantically i'm not cleaning up after
you
i'm not getting you out of bed anymore
and if you get fired and you can't hold
a job i'm gonna have to protect my kids
from a bad example
and i'm going to have to implement some
measures and that may be
us not being together that may be us
having to separate for a time until you
you are taking care of yourself but i
can't have my kids picking up and
learning
more chaos because that's how adhd gets
passed along it's not passed on
genetically it's passed on
environmentally there is a genetic
component but
um does that make sense yeah that makes
a lot of sense
what what what do you say is the best
way to kind of help him
get because i think um it really is
comorbid that adhd
with kind of a feeling of learned
helplessness and depression like no
matter how hard he tries he just keeps
failing
and what he's really struggling to help
yeah it plays into itself right so then
you
you fail at a bunch of stuff you get
fired from a job because you don't show
up on time
and on the way home you stop at four
different fast food restaurants because
you don't care about your nutrition and
then
you have eight diet cokes before you go
to bed which means you don't sleep which
means the whole cycle starts over again
right
yeah yeah then you spin out and the only
way an adhd person
and i'm speaking generally here there's
gonna be somebody out there with it
going that's not my case
well congratulations what most people
the way you turn the alarms off
is through hugs through connection
through excitement and novelty
right and so there are probably some
pretty
uh wild romantic nights y'all have had
am i fair
oh yeah yeah and it's incredible and it
actually makes up for a lot of times
when
the dishes aren't yeah right so they can
be the
best lovers and the best friends
and god almighty they are a beating to
live with and again this is me
this is the pot talking the kettle here
so yeah
what your husband needs to do is this
you all need to number one have you sat
down and had a real hard conversation
with him yet
oh yeah we've had i mean we've had kind
of gentle nudges over the last year of
me being like hey
this is this is hard for me to live with
why don't you go get some treatment
you know and just this last week it
really just like came crashing down like
a bunch of bricks and i was like i
cannot
live with this long term or i'm gonna go
crazy
i'm already getting depressed and i need
you to go get
help i love you i love you for who you
are but in like a romantic relationship
i need this to be a partnership and i
can't
i can't be so unequal all the time and i
need you to go get help where i can't do
this anymore
and so what i want to challenge you to
do is you all go get help
yeah because adhd is healed through
connection it's healed through other
people
and it's healed through lessening the
chaos
and that's not something that people can
do by themselves and i know that's
hard on you because the whole thing you
want is him just to act like a grown-up
and he needs to act like a grown-up and
i'm living proof
you can act like a grown-up i've got my
days
oh god almighty i've got my days right
um i struggle with that but
you can act like a grown-up and you can
hold a job and you can decide
i'm going to eat right and sleep right
so that the next morning i wake up
refreshed and i can be in control of my
executive functioning
and i can over time develop from a child
to an adult i can do all those things
they take practice
and they take connection and so um a
couple of things
like we talked about throughout this
college want to wrap this up and and
really put a bow on this
i want you and your husband to get
together and read this book scattered
together by dr mate i want you to have
a off-site i want you to take him out of
your house i want you all to go
take him out of your house take him out
of y'all's house i want you to go to
lunch go to breakfast
i want you to tell them you're not doing
well and this is not a blow up time this
is a quiet time this
isn't in the heat of some exchange or
yet another time he didn't pick a socks
up or whatever
and i want you to tell me you love him
that he is worth being loved
he is worth being connected to and that
he does not have the skills to be
connected
and that you and him you want to go with
him to a
marriage counselor who specializes in
adhd and there are a bunch of them
and i want you to walk with him through
this journey
for as long as you can it may be that
medication's necessary if he's
if he's 25 35 45 and he's never wrestled
with this
sometimes medication can really help
i've had a buddy of mine a couple of
buddies of mine
who in their 40s and 50s took medication
for the first time and they said it was
like being in a crowded stadium
and someone just turned the noise down
and they didn't know it they
one of them wept as he told me about it
he said i've never could have imagined
it
and by having the volume of the stadium
turned down
then he can finally listen to his wife
and be in connection with her
and that's the medication good it's not
a long-term solution it's not gonna fix
you
but it will give you it may give you
some space to go learn some new skills
or your husband to go learn some new
skills
counseling for disconnection learn how
to be a relationship nutrition
exercise sleep sleep sleep getting out
into nature
playing just enjoying life right
but learning how to do it in the right
times all of these are fixes all of
these are ways to
help a i don't use the word fix i want
to back up all of these are ways to help
somebody with adhd develop into
an adult mind a responsible mind it is a
process
it's an adventure and it's a journey but
if you hear nothing else adhd is
not a disease does not have to be the
rest of your life
and you can fix it you can't cross it
fix again
people try not to say fix we're not
machines you can
develop and grow up i'm i'm testament
here i'm proof of it
i held a day job and i showed up to work
on time i even showed up early today
with my work prepared and you can too